why would we expect them to give to
forsake their mating strategy which is
to spread their seed
but then so isn't that kind of an unfair
deal for men so then if if you
then why would you stay with that person
and cheat if if the person if the
woman's not giving you the youth and
whatever whatever why keep her there and
cheat on her when you can just leave and
be with the youth that you want that's
my thing like I don't understand but I'm
saying well is it fair that women expect
it over a certain age that's the
question
because you give your best years to
someone else
she's talking about going into a new
relationship yeah I know but if you're
going to a new relationship and say this
is the car and the car has been used for
the last 15 years
honestly speaking like who said that we
gave our best to someone else I don't
even know my Maximo or my best probably
I never down to to No One my best
because I don't know I give honestly I
would love someone before I don't know
if I get the maximum I can I don't know
maybe I'm gonna find tomorrow men are
gonna give actually the best of myself
who said that I already gave to someone
else it's about what they think's the
best it's not about you because you're
not the one buying so the guy the guy I
think is the best man yes
men from the ages of 20 to 80 all think
that girls are the most attractive
around 22 to 24. but like this is a man
that cannot stand on his own like
honestly because if you honestly think
that uh you can't stand on his own yeah
because like they actually mind about
what other people think because if
you're telling me that after like the
same for their standards that's shame
it's shame and so guilt need to be no
that's just my point of view I'm saying
that I don't have an inspired day that
doesn't mean that after because I add
six-year relationship I gave my best to
someone no like if a man think this it
means that he's not that confident to
like get my best because if you are a
proper man you're gonna get my best but
see that's shame if you're saying like
no no no
I'll tell you why because you're saying
if you're a real man if you're a proper
man then you would think like me but
that's shaming men for what they want it
doesn't it doesn't have to think like me
I just don't want a man that think in
this way just give me a loan you know
what I mean I want a man that it comes
with confidence say I'm Gonna Get The
Best of You
Point like I'm not spying like just
because I'm 30 or yeah do you think you
determine what the best years are or do
you think they determine what the best
years are I think we pick each other we
should we should actually pick the best
for us me and the man also okay what do
you think I think it depends on the
situation it depends on your ages where
you're right in your life obviously men
prefer younger women so what age ranges
are we saying are their best years I
mean obviously it's different for I
didn't say an age so you could say 40
you could say 45 you could say 35 you
could say 30. that's I don't I don't
tell the men yeah they're 45 on average
men prefer younger women and women
prefer older yeah so I'm guessing the
man is older so so why wouldn't she
expect We're not gonna be like is he
going to go younger than the 40s I'm
saying okay I'm saying isn't that a
unfair deal for men because he's not
getting the things that men value
it depends on the age to say say you're
50 and you're going out with a 40 year
old what do you want bro like you know
what I mean a 35 year old yeah yeah you
should have went for a 30 year old so
why did you go for the food that's
that's the best
okay but the question okay so the reason
I asked this is because I think a lot of
women would have better results if they
took that off the table but they think
they're a higher value than they are
because they're they're selling the same
price they had at 22 that they are that
they are asking for at 35 45 even though
they're on sale they're on discount
because you're you're not as you're not
sorry
was they're getting less value as they
get older in the sexual Marketplace or
wise and more wisdom and all that sort
of an experience you're evolving and
becoming yeah
you're you're telling men what to think
I'm not telling you I'm saying in this
room I'm talking about now she can't
even say it with a straight face no no
I'm saying
that your value is is dropping and the
sexual Marketplace yes well six isn't
all that you bring as a woman you bring
more things to them you bring more
things than just sex if it's just sex
then do you wanna do you want to marry
someone you can't have sex with no do
you want to marry someone you can't have
sex
oh no it starts it starts with sex only
for women for women for women not for
men okay how big is sex to you in a
relationship well it's
it will play it will keep me in a
relationship no honestly like one
question am I like do you add best sex
with uh like 18 20 years old girl or
with a 30 35 40 women
I I don't really tend to rate sex like
that when I go into sex no because we're
saying that we dropping by age
of your point of view just you know I'm
not saying to you know what she's saying
is about men as a collective yeah what
she's saying is correct speaking to the
microwave yeah and what she is saying is
correct because when women get to a
certain age men do see them as less
valuable yeah why I'm asking why because
they had like I said youth Purity you
you automatically see a younger girl she
looks younger she looks more attractive
think that you hope that she's has less
mileage than an older woman so naturally
your first thought is I'm dealing with
someone who hasn't been run through who
doesn't have a higher mileage her face
moves there's no like botox foreheads
right
if you're coming to a guy
over a certain age is it fair to expect
monogamy when you gave your best years
to someone else is that a fair idea is
that no I'm saying is that a fair deal
for men to be monogamous to you when
some other guy got your best years it's
unfair to assume that a woman's given
all her best years to someone else
because
but you're telling men what to Value no
I'm not telling men I'm saying it's
unfair to assume that a woman has given
her best to someone else okay so that's
like going up to guys and say they're
saying hey you know I like 22 year olds
maybe maybe 27 22 to 27 that's that's
what I think's the best and then you're
going up to guys and saying well that
that's not my best years I think my best
years are 30. when they're like um when
you say best what do you mean the most
valuable the most valuable but valuable
in what way in the market wants it the
most okay so what are you talking about
bearing children or bearing children
bearing children the way you look
um less bodies
4E and she's had less bodies than a 20
year old and she looks younger than the
20 year old who's more valuable then
again because because you're looking
you're looking for an extreme exception
show me one 40 year old that looks
younger than a 20 year old I'm 35.
honestly speaking
yeah I'll give you 30. so like 20 okay
that's from you but I'm I'm saying in
general I people don't believe me when I
say my age so if a woman like myself who
doesn't look her age whose body count is
lower than the younger person who's been
run through as you're saying would that
mean that I'm less valuable or more
valuable than a younger girl who looks
older than me and has had more bodies in
in the marketplace you would fall into
an exception you would find that men are
extremely surprised
potentially to the point they probably
may not believe you but if we're talking
about a collective most women will tell
you that from 18 to 25 they got the most
attention from men and after those years
it dwindled and that is the point she's
making what she's making is when you get
to a certain age you become less
desirable
of your eggs are gone by 30. so if you
guys looking for a wife you want someone
that can give him kids so you're less
valuable because you are less likely to
give him kids and you are more likely to
lie about your body count so you could
say oh I have a low body count but a
guy's not gonna believe you he's like 35
you've been in the streets for 15 years
yeah okay
I said I'm the exception or whatever my
eggs dwindling after 30. I think that's
really awful to say that a woman's value
is less because her eggs I said in the
sexual Marketplace okay well in the
sexual Marketplace the woman's value is
less because I eggs whatever because
someone could be 18 or could be
diagnosed with an illness and they can't
have kids ever or there's probably women
that don't even want to have children
and they're living their best life okay
but when you're when you're arguing when
you're arguing the extremes that means
you are because you don't have a good
argument because that's not the rule and
you know I'm I'm just I'm just throwing
out there I'm just saying
go ahead can I just say that
I don't know why women just don't get it
because is it women or me to just say me
no no no I'm not actually agree with you
you're not the only everyone to say you
I'd say you but I'm just saying women as
in general
because it is because 35
right you can be looking good at 35 and
you can get with a man at 35 and say
you're gonna have
you're gonna get with this man you're
gonna have a five-year relationship with
him and then start having kids
think about your 35 you're going to
start having kids at 40. it's not going
to be the same as somebody who is 20
being with that man for five years and
having children it doesn't matter how
good you look it doesn't matter about
your body because you can't beat
biology
that's what's going to happen no but see
this again like what you're saying
Auntie is is a is a great point it's
like women don't get and
the facts are it's like women can come
out and say I want someone who's six
foot plus two that drives a nice German
car that makes x amount of money